this is a global war we want to avoid
all actually this is the impact won't
avoid this implies this global warming
got to avoid this implies this amount of
co2 this implies this amount of
emissions and this is then how do you
regulate that emission cuts amongst the
parties and that's the bit that's really
hard and political not really scientific
at all it's like a small I can a market
trading think that I think as scientists
we want to see that the politicians have
taken the science seriously and that
although I mentioned you know there are
some unknowns in climate science there
there are as much that is known and can
form the basis for decision making so
what I hope not to see is a lot of again
questioning of some of the basic science
of climate change we don't need to do
that and I still think the best thing is
to have emissions targets although many
would say the best way to do this if it
were possible is to have a price on
carbon so you just say look actually if
you make comments gonna cost you if you
don't emit carbon you basically will get
a net benefit and markets although they
are imperfect they can be used to try
and get these changes through it's just
in order to do it with co2 because it's
well mixed you have to have global
agreement on that which is even harder
generally if we can slow the
introduction of fossil carbon into the
biosphere that gives us some time and
it's a little less damaging to the
environment to do that but really it's
the total amount of carbon over many
hundreds of years that is going to be
the problem there are some technologies
that may in the future be able to help
us essentially if you can build
artificial trees that absorb co2 and
then take that co2 and put it back in
the deep in the earth somewhere but so
far that's not it's not really feasible
to do that but theoretically if you
could do that if you extract co2 you
could do it anywhere on the planet do we
would matter what country did it if one
country wanted to invest in that they
could extract that co2 take it in solid
form and put
but so far it's not feasible and we
don't know in the future it will be what
happened for the last you cops is that
the nations come in with pledges really
of what they're going to do and then
there's a kind of carve up to work out
well this would imply and you know they
go a warm glow from this actually it's
two things here one is the pledges
aren't enough at the moment of what to
do with nothing like it and you could
argue well that means to to be targets
gone or you need to think about a new
one the other words that in the past
people have made pledges but not kept to
them so a lot of this is about how
binding the agreement is somehow there
has to be sounds wrong but there has to
be some reason for people to do this
means they have to penalties or
incentives or something that means that
when they when they sign up when
everyone thinks great good on them
they're cutting their emissions by a
five percent when they don't do it you
know you you are somehow exposed and
it's not the next government to comes
down the line I have to take the hint so
I think it's a people talk with binding
targets I think that's what they mean I
mean you you know we're gonna check on
this and other targets being meaningful
but I would rather they're realistic
then optimistic because if we continue
to have agreements pledges that are not
met people were losing more faith in the
process climate change will not go away
and really we're looking at adapting to
kind of fairly business-as-usual
scenario I'd like to be proved wrong